[Musica]
buonasera allora un piacere essere qua a
parlare di futuro e molto spesso mi
domando
cosa vuol dire il futuro di tutti noi lo
traduciamo futuro con i giovani questo è
un grande errore
c'è un futuro per una persona agli 80
anni come c'è un futuro per un ragazzo
di tre anni
perché vedete il futuro e è molto
importante per me come per quella
bambina perché il posto dove passerà il
resto della mia vita e quindi tutti noi
dobbiamo pensare al futuro e riflettevo
sul discorso che faceva prima
anche la professoressa della fatica noi
traduciamo molto spesso in fatica
quello che non ci piace e poi mi accorgo
che alla mia età vado a giocare a
pallone faccio una fatica bestia
eppure mi diverto
allora non è concetto di fatica nel
concetto di che cosa ti dà piacere che
cosa ti dà forse qualcosa di più
profondo che cosa ti dà il senso della
tua vita perché tu esisti cosa stai a
fare al mondo
e allora vado indietro un po da quando
avevo molto più futuro rispetto ad esso
quando ero piccolo e io sono sempre
stato un ragazzo molto fortunato sono
figlio di un mugnaio
sono cresciuto nel mulino con mio padre
dove ha insegnato la prima cosa molto
importante che la scuola non è un
diritto ma te le devi guadagnare e la
mia fortuna avere avuto una famiglia
così una famiglia che come è stato detto
prima da chi parlava mi ha esposto a
tantissime cose diverse e mi ha permesso
di capire il molto presto che cosa mi
piaceva veramente quali erano le mie
passioni
ve li dico anche su un solo 3 1 la più
importante quella che ha guidato tutta
le decisioni difficili della mia vita la
musica
io ancora adesso faccio il dj discoteca
o questo record che sono 43 capodanni
consecutivi che suono e per poter fare
il dj
dovevo siccome ero il figlio del mugnaio
non avevo i soldi ho dovuto costruirmi
gli amplificatori quindi ho imparato
l'elettronica ed è diventata la mia
passione
e poi mi piaceva la velocità quest
adrenalina che ti dà la velocità il
piacere della velocità ecco queste sono
le tre cose che hanno guidato tutte le
decisioni della mia vita e penso ai
ragazzi di oggi
noi come genitori cosa gli stiamo
opponendo di fronte penso che stiamo
facendo degli errori madornali uno lo ha
fatto anche mio padre quando
ha detto una frase e penso che lo
abbiate sentita anche anche voi che ha
fatto dei danni enormi
studia se no vai a lavorare
questa frase ha fatto dei danni enormi
perché ha creato nella testa dei ragazzi
il concetto dello studio come
alternativa al lavoro
studia per lavorare
e allora arriva un altro punto noi come
genitori cominciamo a prendere i nostri
ragazzi fanno le scuole medie poi dice
vede sofà liceo così prendiamo un po di
tempo e vediamo cosa ti piace veramente
invece dovremmo fare l'esatto contrario
dovremmo esporli il primo possibile ma
già dall asilo a tante cose diverse
perché così possono capire dove la loro
passione e noi possiamo capire come
aiutarli nella loro passione e mi sono
messo in testa di fare questo e questa è
la mia idea io penso che
il lascito più importante che possiamo
lasciare nella costruzione del futuro
sia proprio il sistema educativo la
formazione e che cosa facciamo per
costruire il futuro dei nostri figli e
dei nostri nipoti e un altro errore
madornale che stiamo facendo è che
stiamo cominciando a pensare che gli
istituti tecnici sono per gli immigrati
degli italiani fanno il liceo sarà
perché io ho fatto l'istituto tecnico
perché mi piaceva elettronica ma un
errore madornale che dobbiamo liceo
equivalente all istituto tecnico che
equivalenza alle scuole professionali
sono strumenti per imparare a costruire
la tua passione
e allora se colleghiamo tutto questo
filo vi dico un'altra cosa che è
l'ultima prima di arrivare a qual è
l'idea che stiamo cercando di portare
avanti il discorso di mio grande maestro
che era stato il presidente di bm quando
io sono entrato in azienda
eni o presunti che adesso purtroppo non
c'è più che diceva vedi nella tua vita
tu hai tre fasi la prima è impari la
seconda è un guadagno
la terza è servo rendi indietro al mondo
quello che il mondo ti ha dato come
fortuna gli ha cercato di applicarla
questa cosa e quando sono arrivato
come dicevo ho cominciato figlio del
mugnaio sono andato in ibm tecnico di
manutenzione gira per milano a riparare
i computer sono arrivato ad essere
presidente amministratore delegato
25.000 persone sotto di me quando sono
arrivati all'età di 49 anni ho lasciato
tutto e sono ritornato nel mio
territorio per cercare di costruire il
futuro del territorio che mi ha dato
così tanto
che mi ha dato la mia fortuna è che cosa
può si può rendere indietro la prima
cosa che abbiamo fatto nove anni fa
dieci anni fa è stato di prendere 20
disoccupati della val ceno e questo il
cielo e questo fiume
abbiamo fatto dei corsi di cat
e finito il corso magicamente tutti
eventi hanno trovato lavoro
allora è nata questa convinzione le
persone sono le stesse
il territorio e lo stesso abbiamo
cambiato la formazione allora abbiamo
fatto un altro corso poi un altro ancora
più un altro ancora poi due all'anno
adesso stiamo formando qualcosa come 250
persone l'anno e gli stiamo formando sui
mestieri del futuro
noi lavoriamo sulla firma del carbonio
di carbonio sul cad sull'editing
manifactory sulle macchine a controllo
numerico e costruendo questo percorso
abbiamo visto che cosa che bisogna
costruire anche
la parte successiva che quella
dell'università e abbiamo cercato di
fare un po più in grande
abbiamo coinvolto tutte le aziende
dell'automotive della nostra regione
quindi ferrari lamborghini maserati
ducati toro rosso hp e as formula 1
magneti marelli dall'ara pagani
abbiamo provato a disegnare 6 curriculum
di laurea magistrale che servissero per
il nostro futuro e abbiamo capito
improvvisamente che potevamo competere
perché capite bene che mettere ferrari e
lamborghini che si odiano
commercialmente metall intorno a un
tavolo non è facile ma hanno capito
perfettamente che si poteva competere
sul mercato ma cooperare nella
costruzione delle competenze e poi siamo
andati dai quattro rettori delle
università che c'è angelo andrisano e sa
bene di che cosa farlo abbiamo fatto
decine di riunioni chi erano i
professori come facevamo queste cose e
ciascuno di noi si è tassato per
costruire un qualcosa che non c'era
le aziende
e quindi adesso parlo per le aziende ha
messo a disposizione delle due cose più
preziose che avevano una che è una
risorsa preziosa che abbiamo tutti noi è
che qui cito uno dei più grandi filosofi
della storia che sicuramente non
conoscete xkè era mio nonno diceva la
cosa più preziosa che hai e il tempo il
tempo è l'unica cosa che nostro signore
ci ha dato uguale a tutti abbiamo tutti
24 ore per uno ricchi e poveri brutti e
belli e mi diceva sempre se uno ti dice
non ho tempo
in realtà ti sta dicendo tu non sei
importante per me ricordate le sta cosa
quando dite
nono tempo non è vero che non avete
tempo e che preferite un raro in un
altro modo
e allora noi azienda abbia messo la
prima risorsa che il nostro tempo io qui
sto mettendo il mio tempo per ragionare
con prima perché penso di portare
qualcosa ma mi porto a casa molto di più
di quello che sto dando la seconda cosa
che abbiamo messo a disposizione è la
strumentazione gli strumenti che usano i
nostri ingegneri per fare queste
meravigliose supercar e macchine da
corsa e le abbiamo messe a disposizione
degli studenti che in realtà non ci
rendono niente non è un ritorno
dell'investimento
o meglio quando ci dicono che siamo
buoni siamo bravi non è vero abbiamo un
grandissimo interesse solo che è un
interesse nel tempo
e allora abbiamo costruito
e come noi in dall'ara l'han fatto un po
tutte le aziende del nostro territorio
noi abbiamo inaugurato come diceva prima
la presentatrice questa accademia dove
ci sono quattro cose una sono
esperimenti di fisica di meccanica drr
dinamica chiaramente applicata al mondo
del mondo sport per i ragazzi dai 12 ai
16 anni in modo che quando sei in
seconda media in prima media
vieni e provi a giocare e magicamente
impari le leggi della fisica giocando e
non te le scordi più abbiamo un
esercizio è uguale m pera che non se lo
scorda nessuno e questo è il primo
percorso poi dentro questa accademia
abbiamo perso l'ultimo percorso che è
uno di questi corsi di laurea viene
tenuto lì quello di race car design una
terza cosa e metterla la nostra storia
perché chi studia deve poter andare a
vedere le soluzioni che venivano usate
anni fa e capire dagli errori perché
ricordatevi che per essere innovativi
bisogna poter sbagliare se uno non
sbaglia non può essere innovativo sì io
non posso sbagliare sono conservativo
faccio quello che so e noi tutti gli
strumenti di simulazione che abbiamo
sono meravigliosi strumenti per
sbagliare a basso costo e pochi danni e
vedere che le macchine del passato
avevano che ne so il serbatoio della
benzina davanti al pilota e lo
circondava tutto 250 litri di benzina
intorno al pilota e poi ci si domanda
perché morivano bruciati ecco vedere
queste l'evoluzione che c'è stata sulla
sicurezza è molto importante imparare
anche dal passato è l'ultima cosa
abbiamo fatto un
centro congressi da 380 posti aperto
abbiamo preso il rischio di non
ammettere neanche una rete a un cancello
è aperto a tutti perché innovazione vuol
dire apertura se uno abbiamo fatto una
ricerca perché anno fa chiedendo da dove
prendi le idee innovative a più di mille
imprenditori di tutto il mondo solo il
30 per cento delle idee innovative
vengono dai propri dipendenti
il 70 per cento vengono da fuori dai
propri clienti dai propri fornitori dall
università ricerca quindi un'azienda che
vuole essere innovativa per definizione
è aperta
ecco tutti questi ragionamenti
condensati in un luogo in un'idea
gianpaolo dallara che un signore che ha
82 anni
sapete cosa ha fatto lui vissuto una
vita molto sobria gira ancora con la
lancia delta vive nella casa dove è nato
è una piccola casetta nel suo villaggio
di barano i 55 anni tutti i guadagni che
ha fatto i 55 anni
gli ammessi in questo in questa
accademia e lo ha fatto per rendere
indietro al proprio territorio
la grande fortuna che ha avuto lui
ecco questi sono secondo me gli
insegnamenti e gli esempi che ci danno è
questo il mio ultimo messaggio che ci
danno la cosa più importante che il mio
obiettivo di questa sera che è la
speranza noi tutti dobbiamo sapere che
nel nostro piccolo
colonna il nostro grande abbiamo una
risorsa preziosissima che il nostro
tempo e provare ad usarla per qualcosa
che sia al di là del nostro ritorno
immediato al di là di quello che la mia
stessa esistenza
secondo me se tutti noi cominciamo a
ragionare così possiamo fare la
differenza ed è il motivo per cui sono
qui questa sera grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]